and give me a break guys's summer it's
too hot for the hoodie so had a
commenter ask me my thoughts on what
Chris Chibnall has said about the
generalities of his plan for Doctor Who
I had read all this back when he said it
a couple maybe two three weeks ago I
didn't do a video on it at the time
partly because I wasn't sure that I had
enough to say to take up a video on it
I'm still not entirely sure I do but I'm
kind of writing a Doctor Who high right
now with the latest series having ended
and I'm currently working out my next
Doctor Who list which is something I've
been thinking about for a long time and
it's long overdue
so yeah I'm still not mindset I kind of
want to still talk Doctor Who so in case
you either didn't hear what he said or
you kind of forgot because like I said
it's been a little while trying to be
stuff a little more timely than this but
Chris Chibnall basically said a couple
of things he said he was initially
reluctant to take the gig of having
Doctor Who and basically BBC had to woo
him this wasn't something he was
chomping at the bit for and part of the
reason he was hesitant was he didn't
think they would let him do what he
wants to do now he was very vague in
terms of what that was but he did say
that he presented them with a plan
expecting them to go and let's talk
about this from said event that's great
go ahead and do it and one specific
thing he mentioned was a five-year plan
and that's I suppose that's the thing
most worth are kind of examining because
even though we've had Doctor Who show
runners on the show for that long or
longer in the case of Steven Moffat you
have to keep in mind that by large the
way the show has been structured has
been fairly self-contained series two
series now the end of any given series
might set up you know some sort of
teaser for usually the Christmas special
we certainly got that with this most
recent episode but whatever story was
being told within that series gets
fairly closed off so the idea of
inserting a five-year plan could mean a
number of things and if he was concerned
that BBC was going to let him do it
that would lean more towards the more I
don't want to say radical but more
divergent from what we're used to
theories because
was justice oh well I had these five
ideas for a series story so I guess
that's a five-year plan I'm sure he
wouldn't have been nervous about it so
he must be thinking something bigger so
there's a couple of possibilities I
suppose the first is like if we if he
goes like way a lebackes we could be
talking basically something like
Breaking Bad which is more or less one
continuous story told over the course of
five seasons of television I I'm not
sure if I'm going to be hesitant to say
I think this wedding means I'm kind of
hope it doesn't because that is so
divergent from what dr. who tends to do
that I think that might be a step too
far one direction and the other thing
about that is it it is a tricky sort of
way to work when you have as vocal a fan
base that gives as much immediate
feedback as the Doctor Who fan base does
because when you're working series to
series it's easier to make adjustments
now that's not to say that you can't
change anything if you're going you know
with some sort of five year overall
story plan but if you're doing that the
amount of change you can make to
accommodate characters that aren't
landing the way you wanted a character
that was unexpectedly more popular than
you want to cetera et cetera how much
you can adjust that gets hampered
somewhat by whatever the story necessity
is what you already planned are that's
how in something like say Game of
Thrones we've ended up with a small pile
of unresolved plot points that basically
have never come up again they may have
been put in there originally intended by
the showrunners to eventually come up
but you know they decided either wasn't
worth it or the the story wasn't
impacting the way they thought it would
and it just gets abandoned that's the
sort of thing that happens where you go
in thinking this is my clan but they
have to adjust as you go so in terms of
more long-term storytelling that's some
of the potential fall buyers I think
what might be more likely is that he's
going to take what is kind of the
standard series structure of Doctor Who
and stretch it over more years than is
normal so standard series of Doctor Who
by and large has a overall plot going on
in the background
you know things like the mystery of the
impossible girl
the vault bad wolf etc etc etc pretty
much every series had some equivalent of
this so that's going on in the
background of what are more or less
self-contained stories told complete
within single episodes or two parters so
what he may be doing is taking a story
and extending it over multiple series as
opposed to having it get having whatever
the background recurring situation is
get resolved at the end of any given
series and then moving on to another one
and if that is the way he goes that may
that makes more sense to me as in terms
of a logical extension now part of
what's hampering my ability to speculate
too much about this is partly because
honestly speculation doesn't come very
naturally to me but also the fact that I
haven't still yet to see broadchurch so
I don't really have a sense of Chibnall
as a showrunner as opposed to just a
Doctor Who writer so my impression of
broadchurch though was that it was a
continuous story told over the course of
that first series I know it's had a
second series now I haven't really
gauged what the reaction to that is it
even now I don't know again I mean to
get around to it but I haven't caught up
so in any case that is basically one
story this one mystery told over these
multiple episodes and if that's his
comfort zone that's not like I said
that's a big departure from what Doctor
Who usually is but he does say that he
wanted to do something very different
and I don't know I guess I think in some
ways BBC is trying to recapture the heat
a little bit that existed a little bit
more with Tennant at a lot of Smith's
run um you know there are people are
weird there are fans and this happens in
my own comments people like quoting the
viewer numbers and whatever else about
it trying to prove that the show is crap
now I never pay attention to the viewer
numbers but I do know that right now
just simply by looking around Doctor Who
is not the ubiquitous massive thing that
it was under Tennant and
Smith so you know even though I hardly
think it's like crashing or anything
like that again don't quote me not don't
quote leave your numbers I don't care
but in any case the the general sense is
that while the show people may have may
feel it's gotten better may feel it's
gotten worse
the overall impact the show has on the
world at large seems to have lessened
some and I think BBC might be more
willing to roll the dice hoping to shake
that up now things have gotten shaken up
to a certain extent with how things have
gone along so even though Chibnall says
you know he wants to do something really
different the show's been pretty
consistently different up to this point
I mean Matt Smith was a really different
choice and because it was a guy
basically nobody had heard of Peter
Capaldi a huge departure in terms of the
characterization of dr. self the
structure they've altered somewhat they
have split series into more or less two
halves they have had you know ones that
were almost entirely self-contained
episodes they'd had ones that were
almost entirely two-parters so it seems
like BBC is willing to let the the
showrunner experiment a bit more now
whether that is just confidence that the
Doctor Who brand can weather whatever
weirdness or if it's desperation of for
the love of God try anything we want to
get back to our height I am not in a
position to say and I honestly don't
know I like to think it's a fourth it's
the former but it is it's it's possible
that it's the latter we'll see but I do
like that chip know very clearly had big
ideas for this job and that's the only
reason he was reluctant was he wasn't
sure he'd get to execute them that that
somebody would that kind of ambition
that's a good sort of person to put at
the head of this again his writing on
Doctor Who itself I've been okay I
haven't seen broadchurch I've heard it's
great so you know I I am still looking
forward to this I'm obviously very much
awaiting the announcement of who the
next doctor is going to be I say
awaiting I really truly don't want to
know until the regeneration happens but
I have no expectation that they'll be
able to keep it under wraps that long so
I'm just sort of waiting around for when
it drops
obviously what it does I'll have my
thoughts on that and as I said I do have
kind of a doctor who lists that I've
been I've been me to do for quite a
while I kept putting off and to try and
have it out this weekend and saying that
I might have just jinxed it
we'll see but in any case your thoughts
on what you hope Chibnall does or
doesn't bring to Doctor Who whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council geeks give a listen
to the council of geeks podcast and I'm
also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast both available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]